The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Today
we have a lecturer,
guest lecture two of
two, Costis Daskalakis.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS:
Glad to be back.
So let's continue on the
path we followed last time.
Let me remind you what we
did last time, first of all.
So I talked about
interesting theorems
in topology-- Nash,
Sperner, and Brouwer.
And I defined the
corresponding--
so these were
theorems in topology.
Define the
corresponding problems.
And because of these
existence theorems,
the corresponding search
problems were total.
And then I looked into the
problems in NP that are total,
and I tried to identify what in
these problems make them total
and tried to identify
combinatorial argument that
guarantees the existence of
solutions in these problems.
Motivated by the
argument, which turned out
to be a parity argument
on directed graphs,
I defined the class PPAD,
and I introduced the problem
of ArithmCircuitSAT, which is
PPAD complete, and from which
I promised to show a bunch
of PPAD hardness deductions
this time.
So let me remind you the
salient points from this list
before I keep going.
So first of all, the PPAD class
has a combinatorial flavor.
In the definition of the
class, what I'm doing
is I'm defining a graph
on all possible n-bit
strings, so an
exponentially large set
by providing two
circuits, P and N.
P is a circuit of
possible father,
and N is the circuit
of possible child.
And given these two circuits,
I establish a directed edge
between string v1 and string v2,
if they agree on their parent
relationship, meaning v2
believes V1 is his father,
and also v1 believes
v2 is its child.
In that case if this
condition is true,
I establish an edge between
these two pairs of nodes.
And I do the same for
all pairs of strings.
And in the end, I get a graph.
And the problem end of the line
is given these two circuits
and the corresponding graph
that they define on this set,
if the all 0 string is
unbalanced meaning different
in and out degree,
then I want you
to find another
unbalanced node, string,
which is guaranteed to exist
by the parity arguments.
And PPAD is a class of
all search problems in FNP
they are reducable-- polynomial
time reducible to this problem.
I'll remind you also of
structure of the graph defined
by these two circuits.
It's easy to verify that if
my edge definition is this,
then every vertex has in degree
and out degree at most once.
So the graph that's induced
by these two circuits
will have this form.
And basically, I'm looking
for all red points.
For any of these points, any
of these red points, strings,
are solutions, any
unbalanced string,
except for the all 0 string.
If the all 0 string
is not unbalanced,
then I don't want
you to do anything.
If it is unbalanced,
then I'm looking
for any of these red vertices.
So that's the class PPAD, and
it has a combinatorial flavor.
So I'm defining a huge graph,
we have these two circuits.
And I'm asking you to find
any of these red points.
So on the other hand,
sort of like the problems
we were targeting, Nash
equilibrium, Brouwer's theorem,
had a more continues flavor.
So instead of working
directly with this problem,
with the end of the
line, and trying
to reduce this problem
too Nash and to Brouwer
to establish PPAD
hardness deductions,
I actually introduced
a problem that actually
closer to this problem.
It has a continuous flavor.
And it was the problem
ArithmCircuitSAT.
There were a bunch
of problems last time
about the definition
of the problem.
So I decided to be more
explicit about what it is.
So basically I'm
giving you a circuit
that has two types of nodes,
viable nodes, v1 through vn,
and gate nodes, g1 through gn.
Now gate node has one
of six possible flavors.
It could be an assignment
gate, and addition gate,
a subtraction gate, set
equal to constant gate,
multiply by a constant
gate, and comparison gate.
Depending on the
type, it's going
to have from 0 to the
3 inputs, to 2 inputs.
And it always has 1 output.
Now what I wanted to emphasize
is that this graph doesn't
have inputs-- input variables.
Loops are allowed.
And what I want to emphasize
that I didn't emphasise
last time is that variable
nodes have n degree 1,
and gates have 0,
1, or 2 inputs,
depending on their type.
Otherwise for instance,
the out degree of a node
could be arbitrary.
The fan out could be
arbitrary, it doesn't matter.
But you have to respect this.
Every variable node
has n degree 1.
Every gate node has 1, 2, or 2
inputs depending on the type.
There are no edges
between gates and gates,
and variables and variables.
There are only edges
between variables and gates,
and gates to variables.
That's the input.
The input is a circuit
that has this form.
And what I want
you to do is I want
you to find an
assignment of real 0,
1 values to the
variables of this circuit
such that the constraints
of the gates are satisfied.
And here are the
constrains of the gates.
So if they gate is
an assignment gate,
I want the output
node, the node who's
connected to the
output of the gate
has equal value to the node
that's feeding into that gate.
If they gate is
an addition gate,
I want that variable node
who's connected to the output
of the gate to be basically the
sum of the values of the inputs
to the addition gate, except
I'm also going to threshold it.
I'm not going to allow it going
above 1, and so and so forth.
So these are the
gate conditions.
So now what I said last time
is that a satisfying assignment
always exists for this problem.
It's not a priori,
so it a requires work
and actually it is going
through a fixed point
to argue that there is always
a solution to this problem.
What I also claimed
last time is that it's
PPAD complete to find a
satisfying assignment.
So it's a natural starting
point for deductions.
What I also said last
time is that in fact,
I can allow some noise in the
error, in the gate constraints.
I can allow plus minus
epsilon deviation
from the gate constraints.
And so this should
be a minus epsilon.
Sorry about that.
And this epsilon is
part of the input.
I can give as input both
a circuit and an epsilon.
And I will ask you to
satisfy the gate constraints
with an epsilon.
Now last time I also
showed you the structure
the hardness proof
for Nash, which
basically took generic PPAD
end of the line problem.
Today PPAD complete
problem, end of the line,
is embedded into geometry,
into the 3-D cube.
Then we define a version of
Sperner's Lemma, which then
introduced ArithmCircuitSAT.
And I didn't show this
part of the deduction,
and I'm not going to
show it because that's
the complicated part.
But I am going to
show is how to go
from this problem,
the ArithmCircuitSAT
to Nash equilibrium,
just to show how easy it
is to work with this problem
and reduce to other problems.
So that's where I
want to focus on.
So that's the review
from last time.
And this time, I want
to talk about-- I
want to show the PPAD
completeness of Nash
equilibrium.
I'm going to briefly give
two other examples that
have come from combinatorics.
And then lastly, I'm going
to talk about other existence
arguments and the complexity
classes that they define.
So I'm going to introduce these
classes, PPA, PPP, and PLS.
Before I do that,
I also thought it
was a question from last time.
PPAD stands for
polynomial parity argument
in directed graphs,
corresponding to the fact
that this class is defined
with this parity argument
in directed graphs in mind.
So let's focus on this
reduction, from Circuit
to Nash.
I want to introduce a concept
before I show the reduction.
That concept is graphical
games and polymatrix games,
a special case of
graphical games.
So graphical games
were introduced in 2001
by Kearns, Littman, and Singh
as something very natural.
Basically they tried
to capture situations
where the payoff
of a player only
depends on the actions
of a few other players,
because of geographical,
communication,
or other constraints.
So in the graphical game, the
players are nodes in the graph,
in a directive graph.
And a player's
payoff only depends
on her own strategy, as well
as the strategy of the players
that point to him.
For example, this
guy's payoff depends
on this guy's, this guy's,
and this guy's action.
Because all of these guys
point to him, as well as
his own action.
A special case of these
games was actually
introduced much earlier.
So polymatrix games
are graphical games
where the payoff
functions of the nodes
are actually
edge-wise separable.
So for instance, the
payoff of this guy
as a function of
everybody's mixed strategy
is separable overall
edges that point
to him of some pairwise
player function that
has to do with his action
and his neighbor's action.
That's what's written here.
And it's not very hard to see
that any-- so this is a utility
function that depends on
the two mixed strategies.
And by assumption, these
players randomize independently
of each other.
So any such expectation of a
pair of players' strategies
that's are a
product can actually
be written as a quadratic form.
Do you see that?
Let me write on the board.
So again, Xv is the mixed
strategy of player v. Xw
is the mixed strategy of w.
What I mean by Uwv Xu,
comma Xw is basically
an expectation over an
action Su drawn from Xu,
and action is Sw.
Sorry-- Sv drawn from
Xv, Sw drawn from Xw,
independently of-- and that's
just the sum of all the Us
and all the Sws of U, W, sv,
sw, and then the probabilities.
And that's a quadratic form.
So that's what I
mean by this line.
Because players play
independently from each other,
any expectation with respect
to that product distribution
is a quadratic form.
I'm not saying
something interesting.
Good?
So then a polymatrix
game is really,
because of this, defined
by a directive graph.
And then for every directed
edge, and every-- there is
a matrix that defines the
quadratic form for that edge.
So polymatrix game
is easily described.
You can describe by
specifying the graph
and then giving a matrix
what every directed edge.
So bimatrix game are
two player games.
So that's why these
are called polymatrix,
because you have many matrices.
In a two player game, you only
need to give two matrices,
one for a two player game
is just player 1, player 2.
And you give one matrix
for this direction,
and one matrix for
that direction.
So that's a bimatrix game.
This is a polymatrix game.
Now what I want to do
is I want to-- in order
to reduce ArithmCircuitSAT
to Nash, instead what
I'm going to do first
is I'm going to reduce
ArithmCircuitSAT
to finding a Nash
equilibrium in a
polymatrix game.
That's what I want to do first.
After I do that, then I'm
going to reduce it to-- so here
I have many players.
I want to go down
to two players.
But the first step is to
just go to multiplayer
Nash equilibrium.
Then that deduction
is the easy part.
Also this is an easy part.
The hard part happened before.
So now how can we reduce
an ArithmCircuitSAT problem
into a polymatrix game
Nash equilibrium problem?
Like in LP completeness, like in
reductions for NP, RP hardness
proofs, you have
to give gadgets.
You have to identify objects
in polymatrix games that
simulate the
operations that happen
in your circuit over here.
So what I want to introduce is
what is called a game gadget.
These are small
polymatrix games that
do various arithmetic
operations, which
I can then put together to
simulate an ArithmCircuitSAT
problem.
So what I want to do is
I'm going to give you
a flavor of these gadgets.
So I'm going to give you
the addition gadgets.
I want to give you a polymatrix
game that does addition.
So it's going to
have-- this game
is going to have four players.
Everything player will have
just two strategies-- 0 and 1,
two pure strategies, hence the
mixed strategy of that player
is going to be a
real number in 0,
1, which corresponds
to the probability
by which this player plays 1.
So here's the structure
of the gadget.
So this gadget, I'm
showing it here embedded
into a potentially
bigger polymatrix game.
But the gadget itself is going
to have four players, X, Y, W,
Z. Now X, Y are what is called
the input to the gadget.
So these are players
who point to W,
but don't depend on
the actions of W and X
because there are no
directions going the other way.
So these guys don't care about
what these players are doing,
and they serve as an
input to the gadget.
Now this player, W, gets his
input of players strategies
in this gadget.
While X only cares
about the W is doing.
So X and Y are going
to be called the input
players to the gadget.
Z is going to be called the
output player to the gadget.
And W is going to be called
the auxiliary player.
Now what I want to do is I want
to define-- the only thing I'm
going to define is the
payoff function of W
and the payoff function of Z.
And I'm going to define this
payoff functions in a way
that addition somehow
happens at a Nash equilibrium
of this little game.
So I'm going to define
the payoff succinctly.
But then I'm going to
convince you that these really
correspond to tables.
So I'm going to say that W is
paid an expected-- depending
on what he plays.
So if he plays 0, he gets
paid an expected probability
X equal $1, plus
probably X equals
Y equals $1 if he plays 0.
But if he plays 1, he only gets
paid probabilities equals $1.
So in some sense if he plays
0, he looks to the left.
If he plays 1, he
looks to the right.
His payoffs are the sum of
these two guys probabilities
of playing 1 in one case,
and this guy's probability
of playing 1 in the other case.
So that's the payoff function
to W. Now you would ask me maybe
how can you implement
this payoff functions.
And that's actually very easy.
So here's the table for
player W. So when W plays 0,
his payoff is depending on
the strategies of X and Y.
I'm going to define it
to be 0, 1, 1, and 2.
Now notice that in expectation
over X's and Y's strategies,
he's payoff-- so if he plays
0, his expected payoff over X
and Y's strategies is just
the probability that X plays
1 plus the probability
that Y plays 1.
Do you see this
from this matrix?
So what's the expected
payoff to W when he plays 0?
So this is 1 if Y
plays 1, but X plays 0.
And it's 1 if X plays
1, but Y plays 0,
and 2 if they both play 1.
And I claim that if you
properly collect the terms,
this is just equal to
probability Y plays 1,
and X plays 1.
So that's what I claim.
So I covered this line.
This line is also easy to cover
by saying that when W plays 0,
his payoff just depends
on what Z is doing.
And it's going to be like this.
So when W plays 1,
his expected payoff
is exactly the
probability Z plays 1.
So what I've written
here is actually
consistent with some tables
that I'm hiding from this slide.
So that's, I guess, that's
what I want to write.
And then similarly, Z is paid
to play the opposite of W.
What do I mean by that?
I mean that Z's payoff,
when he plays 0,
is exactly 1/2, no
matter what W does.
But if he plays 1, his
payoff is 1 minus W plays 1.
Which again, you
should be able to see
that there's a table, a little
table implementing these payoff
functions.
And that sounds weird.
Why did I define it this way?
Here's my claim.
In any Nash equilibrium
of a game that
contains this little
gadget, the probability
that the output player
plays 1 is basically
the sum of the probability
that the input players play
1 thresholded at 1 of course.
So if this little gadget
that I define here
is part of a bigger game-- now
what can the bigger game do?
So it can fit something into
X. It can take the value of Z
and use it in some other way,
potentially looping around,
doing anything and once, except
the only inputs to W's payoff
are X, Y, and Z.
And the only input
to Z's payoff is W,
but otherwise the
game can be arbitrary.
So if this game
that I define here
is embedded within
a bigger game,
then in anything Nash
equilibrium of that bigger
game, the probability
that this guy plays 1
is exactly the sum
of the probabilities
that these two guys play
1, thresholded at 1.
Now how can we see this?
Why is that true?
It's a little case analysis.
It's very simple.
Let's try to do it.
So suppose that the
probability that Z plays 1
is smaller than the probability
X plays 1 plus the probability
Y plays 1.
Actually, let's do
something else--
it's smaller than the
min between this and 1.
What happens in this case?
So what happens if Z is smaller
than the minimum of these two
values?
What is W going to
do in that case?
AUDIENCE: Is he going to play 0?
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Yeah, because
0 gives him a high payoff,
gives his a higher
payoff than this guy,
but because of that condition.
So this implies that W is going
to play 0 with probability 1.
Now what does this imply?
If W plays 0 with probability
1, what does Z do?
If he plays 0, he gets 0.5.
What if he plays 1?
How much does he get?
He gets 1 because
of that condition.
So he's going to play what?
1.
And so this implies
that-- but how
can 1 be smaller than the
minimal of 1 and something
else?
That's can't be.
So this is impossible.
So do the other side,
or maybe you already
trust me that it's OK.
Let's try to argue that
this cannot be the case.
I don't need to do
the mean anymore
because it can't possibly
be that this guy plays
more than 1 probability.
So this is the only case
I want to consider now.
So what happens in this case?
The same logic.
What does W do?
AUDIENCE: Play 1?
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Has
to play 1 because that's
the better strategy.
And what does he do?
AUDIENCE: Play 0.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS:
But 0 can't be bigger
than the sum of two
r probabilities,
so this and that can happen.
Hence, the only case that's
possible is this one.
So it's very simple.
So the only realization
that one had to do
is that-- where the
arithmetic happens?
It happens in the
mixed strategies
chosen by the players.
That's where it happens.
So this is the addition gadget.
Similarly, one can
define other gadgets.
For example, the
subtraction gadget
is really, really similar to
this except with one change.
I replace this
plus with a minus.
That's the only
change I need to do.
I'm not sure I want to do
it, but in other words,
this table-- I only
change this table
to have 0 here and minus 1 here.
And I've exactly implemented
that, the subtraction.
And the proof is
exactly the same.
You can argue that in any Nash
equilibrium of a game that
contains this gadget, the
probability that this guy plays
1 is actually the difference
of the probabilities
that X plays 1 and Y plays 1,
a probability truncated at 0.
Any questions about
what taking place here?
What we're trying to do is we
want take a ArithmCircuitSAT
instance, and we want to
create a polymatrix game that
simulates that
circuit SAT instance.
And what we need for that is
gadgets, so little polymatrix
games that implement
various operations.
And I showed you
addition and subtraction.
But I claim that
you can implement
a bunch of other gates.
To have a more
succinct notation,
I'm going to use probability
that some node plays 1.
I'm not going to
differentiate that with an X,
and the probability
that X plays 1.
With this notation,
I claim that we
can implement all the gadgets
that we need to simulate
a circuit SAT instance.
So let's look at this table.
So in all these
lines of this table,
Z is the output
player of the gadget,
X and Y are the input
players of the gadgets.
And potentially, the
gadget's implementing
each of these gates
use auxiliary players.
Like in the addition case, I was
using one intermediate player.
He was the auxiliary player.
And the claim is that you
can implement gadgets such
that if any of these gadgets
is contained in a bigger
polymatrix game, then any Nash
equilibrium of these bigger
polymatrix game
these conditions are
satisfied by the output and
input players of the gadget.
And this is as long as you
don't mess up with the gadgets,
meaning that the bigger
the game can have edges
into the input players
of the gadgets,
and edges out of output
players of the gadgets.
But I claim that you can
implement all of the gadgets
that you need.
So in particular, if you have
an instance for ArithmCircuitSAT
you can create the
polymatrix game
by composing gadgets
for each of these gates,
so that at any Nash
equilibrium of polymatrix game,
all gates conditions
are satisfied.
So in particular, you are--
by finding a Nash equilibrium
of this game, you are
solving the instance
of ArithmCircuitSAT
you started with.
So that's the idea.
Any questions about what
happened so far in the lecture?
Questions about this deduction,
or how the gadgets work?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this
give a valid proof
that every instance
of ArithmCircuitSAT
has a satisfying ascendant?
COSTIS DASKALAKIS:
Yeah, that's correct.
Because this is a game.
Some by Nash's theorem,
there is a Nash equilibrium.
Hence, there is a
solution to that.
Because a Nash equilibrium
is a solution to that.
That's exactly right.
Actually that's how we get it.
One thing that's
not exactly obvious,
but you can argue that it's
true is that actually not only
there's always a
solution, but there
is a solution in
irrational numbers
with polynomial description
complexity in the input size.
So that requires some linear
programming techniques.
But that's also use it to show.
A priori, Nash's
theorem will give you
that any solution exists.
It wouldn't give guarantees
about the description
complexity of that solution.
But using linear
programming, you
can argue that there's
always a rational solution
with polynomial
description complexity.
Are you interested in
seeing any of these gadgets?
I've only shown addition.
Do you want to
see anything else?
Do you believe me that
I can actually do that?
AUDIENCE: The
comparison one that
has arbitrary output
for a certain conditions
seems interesting.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS:
OK, I can show that.
So let me try to do
the comparison gadgets.
They're actually simpler
than the addition gadget.
So I want to implement
a comparison.
So I'm only going to have the
input players and the output
player.
And the payoffs of the output
player are-- let's see.
So if you play 0,
then his payoff
is only depends on the
X. And it looks like is.
If he plays 1, let's
see if it works.
I haven't prepared this but
it's easy to figure this out.
Worse case, I'll back track.
So now what I want to argue
is that-- let's bring up
the conditions that
I need to satisfy.
So I want to satisfy
those conditions.
So let's see if I do
satisfy these conditions.
So I messed it up a
little bit, I guess.
So I have to replace
X here and Y here.
Now let's see if that's true.
So I claim that if probability
x is bigger than probability y,
then what do I prefer to play?
I'm prefer to play 0.
Similarly for the other
case, when they're equal,
anything is possible.
It's that's simple.
There's not [INAUDIBLE]
going on here.
Cool.
So I've established
that this direction,
this part of the direction.
Now I want to go down
from a polymatrix game
to a two-player game.
That's the next
part of the lecture.
How do you go down
to two players?
Well the first thing to
note is that all the gates
can be implemented
with bipartite graphs.
So if you remember
my addition gadget,
it had the input and
the output players
on one side and the
auxiliary player on one side.
My comparison gadget does
not satisfy this probability
because the input players
and the output players
are on different sides.
But I claim that you can
implement actually a comparison
by adding an X and an additional
step with a bipartite graph.
So I claim that all
gates can be implemented
with polymatrix games
that have input and output
players on one side,
and auxiliary vertices
on the other side.
So I claim that all my gadgets
are actually bipartite.
So in particularly, I
can color this graph
with two colors, blue and red.
And what I want to do is I want
to create these super players.
I'm going to call the lawyers.
I'm going to have a red
lawyer and a blue lawyer.
And the red player is going to
represent all the nodes that
are colored red in here,
while the blue lawyer is going
to represent all blue nodes.
And what I want to do is I
want to define the lawyer
game in the next slide.
So every lawyer,
so the red lawyer,
his strategy set is the union,
not the product, the union.
That's important,
otherwise my deduction
would be exponentially large.
My induction wouldn't
be a polynomial.
So as a lawyer, and
that poses actually
technicalities in
the construction
that I'm about to present.
But every lawyer will have a
strategy set, a pure strategy
set, the union of the pure
strategy sets of the clients
that he represents.
So the red lawyer
has one strategy
for every strategy
of every red nodes.
The blue lawyer has one
strategy for every strategy
of every blue node.
Now what I want to do
is I want to define
the payoffs in the lower game.
What are the payoffs
in the lower game?
Well, what happens
if the red lawyer
decides to play strategy
i or red client U?
And what if the
blue lawyer plays
strategy j of blue node v?
What are the payoffs
of the two lawyers
in that choice of strategies?
Well, it's going to be exactly
the corresponding payoffs
of the nodes of the
polymatrix game.
So the red lawyer
will the payoff
that U would have gotten
in the polymatrix game
if these two players
played i and j.
And the blue
lawyer's going to get
his client's value,
so v's value,
under the same
choice of strategies.
So in particularly, if there's
no edge between those two nodes
that blue and red
lawyers chose to play,
then nobody gets anything.
The payoff here
is going to be 0.
And if there is a
directed edge from V to U,
then this is going
to be 0, and that's
whatever it is, and vice versa.
But you get the idea.
If the blue lawyer decides
to represent a client,
and the red lawyer decides
to represent another client,
then the payoff of the lawyers
are the corresponding payoffs
that the clients
would have gotten
had they played the strategies
that the lawyers decided
to play for them.
That's the definition
of the lawyer game.
Is this clear?
Now the wishful thinking
is that if X and Y
is a Nash equilibrium
of the lawyer game,
then if I look at the marginal
probability distributions
on the different nodes,
on the different clients
by their lawyer, then
this marginal probability
distribution are a
Nash equilibrium.
So the wishful
thinking is that if I
start with a Nash equilibrium
of the lawyer game,
then if I look at
the distribution
that the red lawyer,
the marginal probability
distribution that the red
lawyer places on every red node
separately, and the
marginal probability
distributions that the
blue lawyer places on
all blue node separately,
so all this collection
of marginal probability
distributions,
that this collection is a Nash
equilibrium of the polymatrix
game.
That's the wishful thinking.
Questions about what
the wishful thinking is?
Of course, this is
wishful thinking
because we know
how lawyers behave.
They only represent
the lucrative clients.
There's no reason that the red
lawyer would have incentive
to choose at least some strategy
to place positive probability
mass on every node
he represents.
Maybe in the Nash equilibrium
of this lawyer game,
some of these
marginal distributions
are actually undefined
because the lawyers-- are ill
defined because the
lawyers place 0 probability
mass on the strategies
of those nodes.
So that wishful thinking
isn't going through.
But there is some truth to that.
So there is a way to fix it.
So here's how we're going
to fix the lawyer game.
So we know what lawyers like.
They like money.
So we're going to define
a high stakes game.
But the lawyers
are going to play
on the side at the same
time as the actual game
that we're interested in.
So for a lot of cash-- so those
are the stakes of that game.
We're going to do the following.
So some terminology first.
So suppose that we had
lots of generalities.
Suppose that every lawyer
has n clients he represents.
And let's label the
red lawyer's clients
1 through n, and the blue
lawyer's clients 1 through n.
If you know one of the two
lawyers have fewer clients,
then we can pad this
with dummy players
and that doesn't change the
polymatrix game's equilibria.
So suppose that both lawyers
represent the same number
of players, clients.
And let's label both lawyers'
clients one through n,
in an arbitrary way.
The strategies of
the high stakes game
are exactly the same as
the strategies of the game
that I showed in
the previous slide.
In particular,
the red lawyer has
the union of the
strategies of blue nodes.
And red lawyer has the
union of the strategies
of the red nodes.
Now what's the high stakes game?
Suppose that the red player
plays any strategy of client j,
and the blue lawyer play
any strategy of client k.
Then if they choose
different clients,
they both get 0 dollars.
But if they choose the
same client-- I mean,
it's not the same client, it's
the same label of a client
because they each represent
different clients.
But if they choose different
labels, then they both get 0.
If the choose the same
label, whoever it was,
the red lawyer
gets a lot of cash,
and that blue lawyer
loses a lot of cash.
Again, so this game has the same
strategies as the lawyer game
that I showed in
the previous slide.
Except now in this game,
all the lawyers care
about is the labels
of the clients
whose strategies they choose.
So if they choose a
strategy of a client that
has the same label, then the
red lawyer gains a lot of money,
and the blue lawyer
lose a lot of money.
But if they choose strategies of
clients with different labels,
then they both get 0.
In other words in some
sense, the blue lawyer
is trying to avoid
the red lawyer,
and the red lawyer is trying
to catch the blue lawyer.
So now this is a
simple 0 sum game.
And it's not hard to
see that in any Nash
equilibrium of this
game, the lawyers are
going to represent every client
with the same probability.
So each lawyer
assigns a probability
exactly 1/n to the
set of his strategies
corresponding to
each of his clients.
So the high stakes
game has the property
that the lawyers represent
all their clients
with the same
probability distribution,
and you can divide the
probability distribution
in an arbitrary way within
the strategies of each
of their clients in this game.
That's easy to see just by the
symmetry of this games, that
has to be true.
And with these two
definitions, the game
that I'm going to do for my
reduction from polymatrix games
to two player games is going to
be the sum of these two games.
So this is the game
that I defined earlier.
And this matrix
is a block matrix.
So this is a block of strategies
corresponding to-- this matrix
is a matrix that is a constant
matrix where everything is big.
And this block
corresponds to-- these
are the strategies
of client with label
1 for the red lawyer.
And this is the
strategies of the client
of the blue lawyer with
label 1, and so on so forth.
So this is a block matrix.
And there are ms and minus
ms in this diagonal blocks,
and everything else is 0.
So that's the high stakes game.
It's played along
blocks of strategies
because all I care of
is the label the client
I'm choosing for each
of these lawyers.
Well, this is a more
fine-grained game,
where I not only care about
which clients and choosing,
but also which strategies of
these clients I'm choosing.
And I'm going to choose
an m that overwhelms
the payoffs in this games.
So this condition is OK
for what I'm about to say.
But think of m as huge
compared to the maximum utility
in this game times the number
of clients in that game.
AUDIENCE: Just to make sure
I'm understanding this so far--
so in the naive game,
if the red guy chooses
strategy and the blue
guys chooses a strategy
and the two vertices
they choose from
are not connected by an
edge, then they both get 0.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Yeah.
And if they're connected,
they get payoffs
that the corresponding
nodes would have gotten--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
vertical edge,
one is the one on the outgoing
vertex will still get 0.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS:
Exactly, yeah.
Any other questions
about-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Even with a
really large choice of m,
can't it still mess up
the values a little bit?
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Yeah.
It will mess it up a little bit.
So the Nash equilibrium
of this game,
the addition of these
two games, is not
going to have the property
that this game by itself had.
But it's going to be very close.
And I'm going to be
specific about it.
AUDIENCE: So the choice of me
is so that the isn't that big.
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Even
for arbitrarily large m,
I can't actually quite show
that the lawyers represent
their clients exactly equally.
But I can bring it close.
And the larger m is
the closer the come.
In particular, I can show
the following statement
that in any Nash equilibrium
of the combined game, if X used
the total mass that
the red lawyer places
on the union of strategies of
node U, then that's about 1/m.
But there is the matter that's
the case with m, and similarly
for the blue lawyer.
So approximately they're
representing all their clients.
And if I choose m huge
then at least my marginals
are well-defined now.
So there is probability
mass on every client
and I can define these
marginal distributions.
Now whether these distributions
are useful or not,
we are about to see.
But what I'm saying here
is that as far as deciding
how to split the
pie into my clients,
really the large
game is what matters.
The high stakes game
is what matters.
Because if I make a mistake, m
is huge, some huge [INAUDIBLE].
So for splitting,
for deciding how
to split my total unit
of probability mass
into my clients, only the high
stakes game-- essentially,
only the high
stakes games matter.
On the other hand, when it comes
to having decided how much mass
to put on the unit of a
particular node strategies,
deciding about the fine-grained
decision of how to allocate
that Xu into the different
strategies on that node U, then
actually only the
small game matters.
And the reason is
that the payoff
different of the red lawyer
from strategies Ui and Uj--
so to distinguishes
between strategies
i and j of node U, the payoff
difference between these two
choices doesn't have m in it.
If you actually look
at it, m goes away.
There's no m in the payoff
difference between these two
options.
So which one is better
doesn't have m in it,
essentially doesn't
have m in it.
There is some m in
here because this I'm
summing over all nodes,
and different nodes
have different sum
of probabilities.
But I'm going to get to that.
But trust me that when
the red lawyer is trying
to decide how to allocate this
Xu probability that he has
decided to allocate
on the difference
strategies of node U, he looks
at this difference, that's
the difference in
the two payoffs.
And essentially there's
no m in this equation.
So we're going to see when m
gets into the picture and why.
But this is just from the
definition of the game.
Again, this is exactly true.
The difference of the two
payoff is exactly this.
Now from that
equation, it follows
that if they lawyer decides
to put positive probability
mass on a particular strategy i
of that node, then for all js,
for all alternative
strategies of that node
that he could choose, it
better be that this payoff
difference is positive.
And that really, really looks
like the condition of the Nash
equilibrium conditions for the
client, if you think about it.
Because if I define the
marginal probabilities
of node U on these
two strategies,
on these strategies, then this
is really the Nash equilibrium
condition for that node
U. The only problem
is to go from this equation
for the unmarginalized
probabilities Vy,
Vl's, to the marginals.
I'm dividing with something,
and that something
is an equal for all these.
So if it was equal,
then these marginals
would actually be
directly Nash equilibrium.
Because this condition I
could just divide by 1/n,
and this would be made
marginal probability.
And that's exactly the
equilibrium condition
for the client U.
The problem is that these
Xvs are not all equal.
Yvs are not equal.
So I cannot just divide by 1/n
and claim that the equation is
still true.
But the point is that
this error doesn't
create too much problems in
the equilibrium conditions.
And OK, it's not going
to be an exact Nash
equilibrium for the
polymatrix game,
but it's going to be
an approximate one.
And because I can take n
to be as large as I want,
I can make this approximation
go to 0 as fast as I want.
And remember this
ArithmCircuitSAT problem
allowed some error in it.
So what effectively
is going to happen
here is that I'm going to get
an approximate equilibrium
of the polymatrix game.
So that would correspond to
an approximate equilibrium
of the arithmetic SAT
problem I started with.
But this approximation
can back accommodated,
and the problem is to PPAD hard.
So that's approximately
how the argument works.
The fact that the
disagreements aren't uniform
doesn't really matter as long
as n is chosen large enough.
I went a bit too fast.
I didn't mean for this
to be very detailed.
But I meant to convey
the bigger picture.
And the bigger
picture basically says
that you can analyze what
happens in this lower
game in two steps.
In one step, you argue that
the lawyers approximately
represent all their clients.
In the other step,
you have to decide
how these lawyers allocate
their probabilities
to the different strategies
of a particular node.
That leads you to write down
this difference of payoffs
that the lawyer is
experiencing when he switches.
This is tracking how much
better the expected payoff
from this strategies is
compared to that strategy.
And by the equilibrium
conditions of the lawyer game,
you get the inequality I
showed in the next slide
that if the lawyer decides
to place positive probability
mass to a strategy
i of node U, then it
must be that there is no
alternative strategy, Uj,
that would give them
the better payoff,
so you get this condition.
And that's essentially
the equilibrium condition
for the polymatrix
game, except that you
need to normalize these guy.
And when you try to
normalize these guy,
you run into the
problem that the lawyers
don't play uniform
strategies for their clients.
But they play approximate
uniform distribution
of their clients.
So this inequality gets
messed up a little bit.
So effectively that
means that the players
are almost best responding.
The marginal distributions on
an approximate Nash equilibrium
of the polymatrix game.
Also because the polymatrix game
came from my ArithmCircuitSAT
problem, an approximate
evaluation of that problem.
But theses are all PPAD hard,
as I pointed out earlier.
That's the high level idea.
And trust me, the details
are not hard at all.
OK
So you just have to trust me
that the approximate uniform
distribution of
the claim are true
and that dividing by
approximately 1/n here
doesn't mess up this
condition too much.
So this was the end of
the proof basically.
That's basically
how the proof goes.
So if have this,
it's easy to do this,
and then it's easy to go here.
Any questions?
Now the reduction I
showed you was not
from the original paper.
It was established by a follow
up paper by Chen and Deng.
In that original paper, we
actually took this problem
in reduced to 4-player Nash.
The proof is identical
to the one I showed you.
The only reason that we went
to four players instead of two
players is that our gadgets
were four-partite instead
of bipartite.
So we had four colors
and four lawyers.
Now why did we have
four-partite gadgets?
Well, we were being a bit silly.
We had in our
arithmetic circuit,
we had an extra gate,
which plus multiplication,
not by a constant, but the
multiplication of two numbers.
And you can show that
this-- but we didn't use it.
We were being a bit silly.
We had this gadget here
that we weren't using.
And it was hard to-- actually
it's impossible to make it
into a bipartite gadget.
So in our recent paper, we made
it into a four-partite gadget.
And then, in the
followup paper we
actual managed to reduce it
to a three-partite gadget.
But then this multiplication
gadget actually you can show
cannot be reduced to bipartite.
So these guys observed
that actually we
are not using multiplication.
So you can implement all
gadgets that we actually
used with partite graphs.
So you can go down
to two lawyers
instead of three lawyers.
So it felt like leaving money
on the table, but that's OK.
That's my discussion of
PPAD-completeness of Nash.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Obviously,
in zero-sum games,
it's easy to find
an equilibrium.
Is there something in
between zero-sum games
and general two-player
games for which any hardness
result is known?
COSTIS DASKALAKIS: Yeah.
A natural way to interpolate
between zero-sum games
and general two-player
games is the following.
So in a zero-sum game let's
call R and C the payoff matrix
of the two players.
In the game of zero-sum, if R
plus C, the sum of these two
matrices is identically 0, as I
claimed in the very first slide
I gave last time.
Now you could call a game
rank-r if R plus C has rank-r.
Now what is known is that
rank-1 games can be solved in P.
I believe that it's known that
rank-3 games are PPAD hard.
And you should look at the
paper by Mehta, Ruta Mehta
in '14, I believe,
where she shows that.
She might even be showing
rank-2, but I'm not sure.
Maybe there is some gap there.
Maybe it's even-- so there is
a constant where it's already
PPAD hard.
And while I'm here, an
interesting open question
is approximate equilibrium.
So interesting open problem--
approximate Nash equilibria.
Even into two-player
games, we've
don't know how to find them.
So let me remind you what this.
So a Nash equilibrium is
a pair of strategies such
that no one has an incentive to
change his randomization given
what the other player is doing.
And epsilon Nash equilibrium is
when this condition are true to
within an order of epsilon.
So no player has incentive, more
than epsilon, additive epsilon
incentive, to changed
his strategies.
So at most, additive
epsilon incentive to change.
Now what do we know
about these problems?
Well, if the input
to your problem
is a game and an epsilon, then
it follows from those results
that that's PPAD complete.
Now it's even true that
if your input is a game,
and you have a
prespecified epsilon that's
inverse polynomial in
the size of the game,
so that the input
is a game, and there
is a inverse
polynomial function,
and that's your epsilon.
And you want to find an
inverse polynomial Nash
equilibrium of this given game
that's still PPAD complete.
But what is not known
is epsilon constant.
How hard is it to
find equilibria
when epsilon is a constant?
And if your matrices
have entries in 0,1,
then we know how to
do this in time n
to the order log n
over epsilon squared.
We know that there is no
FPTAS for the problem because
of actually these
results, follow up results
to these results.
But what I claimed earlier about
inverse polynomial accuracy
prohibits an FPTAS
for the problem.
But a PTAS is possible.
What we have is a quasi-PTAS.
So if you have an
n-th strategy game,
and you're interested in
some constant epsilon,
then we can get you an epsilon
Nash equilibrium, n to the log
and over epsilon squared time.
And because I'm looking
at additive of epsilons,
I'm also normalizing
my payoffs to be 0, 1,
so that epsilon is related to
the maximum payoff of the game.
So that's what we have.
And it's a great open problem
if you can improve this, or show
a lawyer bond.
That's a great open problem.
Speaking of which, if the
rank of this game is up to,
I believe, logarithmic,
we know how to get a PTAS.
Now I don't have
too much time left,
so I guess I had two
options for today.
One was to talk about
different problems
that you can show PPAD hard, or
to talk about other existence
arguments.
And I think I only have
time for one of the two.
The other option is to show
other arguments of existence
in TFNP.
So two examples,
or other argument?
What do you guys vote?
So who wants two other examples?
OK, who's giving the count?
Who wants other
existence arguments?
So I think there's a slight
majority for other existence
arguments, so I'm
going to show that.
PPAD is founded on the
directed parity argument.
Other natural arguments of
existence in combinatorics
are the following,
and each of them
is going to correspond to a
different complexity class.
This is a parity argument
on an undirected graph
if an undirected graph has
a node of odd degree then
it must have another
node of odd degree,
also known as the
handshaking lemma, I believe.
Well this is another simple one.
If a DAG, any DAG
has a sink, that's
going to give rise
to the class PLS.
And that's the
pigeonhole principle.
If you have a function
mapping n elements,
n minus 1 elements, than
there is a collision.
That's going to give
rise to the PPP.
So PPA stands for
polynomial parity
on undirected graphs, PLS,
polynomial local search, PPP,
polynomial pigeonhole principle.
And I'm going to
define them formally
in the next few slides.
So I'm going to start
with PPA because it's
very similar to be PPAD,
except there's no direction.
And the input to the
problem is a circuit
that induces a graph
of [INAUDIBLE] strings.
So the circuit gets its input at
nodes, and outputs two strings.
Gets one string,
outputs two strings.
Now this circuit induces
a undirected graph
over all possible strings
in the following way.
There is a node between
string 1 and string 2
if v1 is in the
output list of v2,
and v2 is in the
output list of v1.
So this circuit gets
n-bits as input,
and has two n-bits as output.
And no matter what it is,
it doesn't use a graph
over strings that places an
edge between these two strings,
if v1 is in the output
list of v2, and vice versa.
Now in the same reasoning as
last time, the same spirit
as last time, any
input C is going
to reduce a graph with
a particular structure.
What's that structure?
The odd degree of
every node is what?
At most 2.
Hence the graph that is
induced by any given circuit
is going to be a collection
of isolated vertices, cycles,
and paths.
The odd degree node
problem is the following.
If the 0 string has
odd degree, then I
want you to find me another
node with odd degree,
which we know exists by
the handshaking lemma.
Otherwise, if 0 to the n has
even degree, just say, yes,
and call it a day.
Now PPA is the class of
search problems in NP
that are reducible, polytime
reducible, to this problem,
to the odd degree node
problem, whose graph structure
is very similar to PPAD,
except there are no directions.
So any circuit C defines
a graph of this form,
except the graph is over
exponentially many vertices,
so we cannot just go
and check every node,
every node's degree.
So the question is if 0
to the n has odd degree,
then there must be another
node of odd degree.
Any of these nodes is a valid
solution to the problem.
Something that I didn't
mention before for PPAD,
but it's useful to
mention, and I'm also
going to mention it
for PPA, if I insist
on finding the other
end of this path,
of the specific path
that started at 0,
the problem is not in FNP.
So it's crucial that
given the unbalanceness,
or the odd degree
of this node, I'll
allow you to return any
other odd degree node.
That's very crucial.
If I insisted on
you returning me
the other endpoint on the
path that starts at 0,
that's above NP basically
because there's no source
certificate that this node
in the other end of the path
starting at 0.
So it's very crucial
that I allow you
to return any odd degree node.
Now an interesting problem
that is in this class,
and as far as we
know, not in PPAD,
is the problem Smith, which
is given a Hamiltonian
circuit in a
3-regular graph, find
me another Hamiltonian
circuit in this graph.
Now this graph is not
exponentially big.
It's actually a graph
that you can write down.
So I give you a
graph explicitly,
and I also give you
a Hamiltonian circuit
in this graph.
I claim that there is
another Hamiltonian circuit.
The question is find it.
Now why is there always
a Hamiltonian circuit?
Well, that follows
from a theorem by Smith
saying that-- a theorem by Smith
implies that there's always
another Hamiltonian path.
And let me actually
show it to you.
It's very simple.
So here's is actually a copy
from Papadimitriou's '94 paper.
I guess there's a
missing apostrophe here.
So here's the input graph.
And obviously, this is
a Hamiltonian circuit.
So I'm following the outer
boundary here, going inside,
and then coming back here.
That's the Hamiltonian circuit.
And here's the same
circuit, except I removed
one edge, x and y.
And here I'm showing
a bunch of operations
you can do this
Hamiltonian path-- this
is a Hamiltonian path-- to
create another Hamilton path
with the same edge missing.
Hence, out of that edge, you
get another Hamiltonian circuit.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
is very simple.
So what you do is the following.
So you start with--
it doesn't matter.
You can start with
an arbitrary node.
All the circuits I'm
going to be defining,
will have x as one
of the two endpoints.
But the other endpoint is
going to be moving around
and in the end, is going
to get back to this vertex.
Hence, I can knock that edge
back and get the circuit.
So I started with the circuit.
I remove one edge, x and y.
And I'm about to
show you that there
is another Hamiltonian path
that misses the same edge,
but is different than this one.
So it's going to be that one.
Now let me try to
argue that that
is another Hamiltonian path
that is missing the same edge.
How am I going to do that?
Well, in this sequence
of Hamiltonian paths
that I'm going to define,
x is going to stay fixed,
y is going to be moving around.
Now let's land somewhere
in the middle, here.
So now y is this guy.
y, because the
graph is 3-regular,
and y is an endpoint,
there's exactly
one edge that's used in
the Hamiltonian path.
And there are two
edges that are missing.
I'm going to try to add both
of them and get a circuit--
and get a path, a
Hamiltonian path.
What would happen if I tried to
add this edge into this path?
Well, that wouldn't
be a path anymore.
So because this guy would have
degree 3 if I added that edge.
Now have two kill one of the
two edges adjacent to this node.
And I'm going to kill the one
that the maintains the fact
that the graph is connected.
If I add this edge, and I
kill this edge, I'm screwed.
The graph is not
connected anymore.
So I'm going to kill that edge.
So what happens here?
I added that edge, and
I killed that edge.
And this what I got.
If I tried to add this
edge, then this node
will have degree 3.
I have to kill either
that edge or that edge.
I can kill exactly one to
avoid disconnecting my graph.
And I'm going to be
killing that one,
and that's going
to bring me here.
So every Hamiltonian path
has exactly two neighbors
corresponding to adding
one of the two missing
edges from the y
endpoint of that path.
And there's only one
way this thing can stop,
by arriving at y.
If I don't get
endpoint y to come back
to its original position
I will keep going.
In other words, like my proof
[INAUDIBLE], what I did here
is I defined a
neighborhood relationship
between Hamiltonian
paths, which was
adding an edge, one
of the two missing
edges from the endpoints.
And another, the only stopping
condition is if I get here.
And that's why Smith is in PPA.
Now it's a very
interesting problem
to show that this
is PPA complete.
Let me define the class PLS.
That was define earlier
by Johnson, Papadimitriou
and Yanakakis.
Now I want to implement a class
that exploits this argument,
that every DAG has a sink.
The way I'm going
to do that is I'm
going to give you two functions.
Function C is going
to take-- both of them
will have n-bits as inputs.
This guy, C, will output
a list of strings,
a list of k strings.
So it has n-bits as input,
and k n-bits as output.
While this guy is
outputting some real number,
I mean, some rational
number, whatever.
But I interpret the output
of the circuit as a number.
I interpret the
output of this circuit
as a list of other strings.
I add that's between-- given
these two circuits, that
induces a DAG, I claim,
in the following way.
I add an edge from
v1 to v2 if v2
is in the adjacency list of
v1, and the score of v2 two
is better than the score of v1.
Then and only then, I add
an edge from v1 to v2.
And obviously, this is a DAG now
because I'm increasing my score
as I go along.
So I cannot come back
to where I started.
So the problem that
I want to define
is the FindSink problem, which
is given two circuits as above,
find an x that has a
better score than any
of the adjacent vertices.
And such a thing has to exist
because if I define this graph
and find any sink
of this graph, this
will satisfy this property.
The class PLS are all
search problems in the P,
but are polynomial
time reducible
to this problem, FindSink.
The picture for this
problem is this,
exponentially large graph.
But there is a DAG
that's implicitly
defined by these two vertices,
by these two circuits.
And all of these are solutions.
An interesting
problem in this class
is the LocalMaxCut
problem, a relative
of the well-known MaxCut
problem, which is NP complete.
In the LocalMaxCut problem, I'm
giving you a weighted graph.
And I want a partition
that's not globally
optimal, but locally
optimal, meaning
there is no single
node I could move
from one to the
other side of the cut
to improve the cut value.
Now if the weights were
bounded and integral,
this wouldn't be a hard problem.
But for arbitrary
weights, it's actually PLS
complete to find a
local maximum cut.
Final problem, and
I'm concluding,
is final class is
the class PPP that's
trying to implement the
pigeonhole principle.
Here I'm giving you
a circuit that has
n-bit input and n-bit outputs.
The collision problem
that I want to define
is given sets of
circuits, either find
me an x that maps
to the 0 string,
or find me a pair x and y
that map to the same string.
Clearly, by the pigeonhole
principle if nobody goes to 0,
there must be two
guys that collide.
So this problem is also total
by the pigeonhole principal.
So it always has a solution,
no matter what the circuit is.
And the class PPP is
all problems in NP that
are reducible to this problem.
Finally, the hierarchy of
problems I defined is this.
P, FNP, there is total
FNP somewhere here,
which I don't show.
And these are the relationships
of these problems.
I haven't shown that
these arrows true,
that this is a subclass,
PPD's a subclass
of these two subclasses.
This is easy.
This is a simple exercise
we can think about.
This is basically
my introduction
to PPA, PPAD and
related classes.
The final thing that
I want to point out
is answering a
question that was asked
after the previous
lecture, which
was why did you
define these classes,
and not just a TFNP
complete problem.
Why did you have to pay special
attention to precise existence
argument that gives
rise to the guarantee
that your problems are total?
And the reason for that
is that actually TFNP
is not what's called
a syntactic class.
In other words, if I give
you a problem with TFNP--
if I give you a Turing machine,
you cannot decide whether that
is computing a total problem,
that no matter what the input
to that machine is,
there's always an output.
So I had to pay attention to the
specialized existence arguments
because for specialized
existence arguments,
I know a priori that
the problem is total.
So in particular, no matter
what circuit I give you here,
I don't even have
to check anything.
No matter what input you give
me, I know there is a solution.
No matter what pairs of
circuits you give me here,
I don't need to check anything.
I know the answer
to this problem--
there's always an answer to this
problem, and so on, so forth.
No matter what you
give to me as input,
it is important to
define complexity classes
for which you can show
hardness results to find
complete problems.
Otherwise, you
would have what is
called promise classes, which
are not amenable to showing
the completeness results.
On that brief not,
I want to stop.
Thanks a lot.